am nächsten freitag findet sie statt die
verleihung der schweizer filmpreise 2016
und bevor wir wissen wer die begehrten
trophäen mit nach hause nehmen kann
wollen wir diskutieren und zwar lustvoll
über die nominierten spielfilme und
dokumentarfilme und wir das sind die
filmhistorikerin marsberg der
filmkritiker von der nzz am sonntag
christian jungen und mein kollege von
srf serien petersen herzlich willkommen
ja wir reden über filme die unserer
meinung nach zu reden geben wir reden
aber auch über themen die zu reden geben
nämlich darüber dass die zwei
erfolgreichsten schweizer filme des
letzten oder dieses jahres nämlich
schale mosley und heidi nur in
nebenkategorien nominiert sind und nicht
für den besten spielfilm ball zum
beispiel heidi über eine halbe million
zuschauer in die schweizer kinos lockte
und weltweit bereits 24 millionen
im gegensatz dazu köpfe 300.000 menschen
haben diesen kleinen film gesehen in der
schweiz
und er ist nominiert in fünf kategorien
auch als bester schweizer spielfilm
marsberg körper ein film auf türkisch
der voll und ganz in der türkei spielt
ist es einfach ein so viel besserer film
als die jugendbuchverfilmung heidi ich
glaube es geht hier nicht ums besser
sondern um welche art von film das ist
heidi und schellen ursli das sind
blockbuster mehr nach dem amerikanischen
oder internationalen mainstream und
körper ist einen alten film und
blockbuster das heißt filme die aus
erfolgreich schon im vornherein
kalkuliert werden in beiden fällen sind
das für die auf sehr beliebte
jugendbücher basiert sind wo der erfolg
gar nicht aus dem filmischen kommt
sondern aus dem bekanntheitsgrad in der
gesellschaft aus den sicheren
kulturellen werten und ich denke die
firma dem i hat es offenbar wie
einige goutiert dass solche firmen mit
den grünen kommen aus anderen firmen die
mit vergleichbar bescheidenen budgets
gemacht werden und die mehr eine
persönliche handschriftliche da will ich
natürlich gleich zu christian jung
kommen sie sind in dieser akademie der
filmakademie die bestimmt welche filme
gewinnen welche filme nominiert sind ist
die akademie so elitär das eben
publikumslieblinge überhaupt keine
chance das ist so und zwar schon seit
längerem
es war zum beispiel auch so dass jackie
testate gewonnen hat und nicht der
verdiente damals konnte ich das
künstlerisch gesehen nachvollziehen
diesmal findet es absurd vor allem im
fall von heidi dass du nicht nominiert
ist und ich sehe diesen gegensatz
autoren kino blockbuster überhaupt nicht
wenn man nämlich das autorenkino per
definition ernst nimmt dann wurde das ja
von dvd und konsorten in den 50er jahren
gerade am beispiel von mainstream filmen
definiert man hat gesagt hitchcock ist
nicht bloß ein trick meister sondern er
hat eine handschrift und ich glaube kein
mensch würde sagen dass xavier koller
oder allein spuren einfach keine
handschrift wenn man jetzt auf die
oscars schaut um die saison sie schauen
sich ja viele solche verleihungen auch
an ist die schweiz eine ausnahme sind
eben bei uns nur die publikums filme
schlechte m rennen aus die kunst film
sage ich nein das ist eigentlich immer
so wenn die branche selber bestimmt
welche filme prämiert werden
und da setzt sich immer der anspruch
durch aber auf der anderen seite auch
das etablierte das gut vernetzte also
die leute die gut vernetzt sind oder man
kann es auch böse ausdrücken in der
schweiz
der filz setzt sich durch besonders
berüchtigt ist ja da die romandie oder
die romands die meistens nur sich
gegenseitig die stimmen geben in diesem
jahr ist da er zum glück nur ein film
zur auswahl qualität von lionel baier
und ich bin auch der meinung dass die
akademie die richtigen filme gewählt hat
so anders aus der jungen weil ich finde
die sind einfach künstlerisch wertvoller
das andere
heidi und schellen ursli sind gut
gemachte produzenten filme nicht
autorenfilme es ist aber so dass sogar
der präsident der akademie christian
frey gesagt hat ich bin enttäuscht von
der
die mieter sie so urteilt christian
richtig meint der schweizer filmpreis
wurde auch gegründet als ein
werbeinstrument für den schweizer film
und wenn man dann quasi diese filme die
so beliebt sind wie schellen ursli und
heidi links liegen lässt dann verspielt
man natürlich auch die chance für den
werbeeffekt und ich finde
vielleicht zeigt diese nicht nomination
auch ein problem dieses toplos es fehlt
nämlich eine wichtige kategorie der
beste regisseur
die gibt es gar nicht und wenn ich zb
die oscars schaue dann interessiert mich
am meisten best picture und am
zweitmeisten bester regisseur
und hätte man wenigstens diese kategorie
gehabt hätte man vielleicht so wie kohle
nominieren können und honorieren können
dass das sehr gute ausstattung hat diese
beiden filme ich meinen verschenken
haben die kulissen nachgebaut und das
ist auch künstlerisches handwerk dass
ihr völlig ignoriert wurde
aber dafür wurde nicht links liegen
gelassen beide filme sind zwei mal
nominiert aber halt nicht innerlich in
den kategorien genau aber der film und
ich denke ich würde gerne in diesem film
hineinschauen in die nominierten
deswegen reden wir auch darüber körper
ist der film mit den meisten
nominationen von der regisseurin essen
essen ii sieg ist deutschschweizer
türkische staatsbürgerin und sie hat
schon zwei mal den schweizer filmpreis
gewonnen für ihre kurzfilme und jetzt
eben ihr erster langfilm fünf kategorien
nominiert wir haben es gesagt und damit
wir den eindruck bekommen von diesen
film schauen wir uns eine längere szene
an aus diesem episodenfilm aus der
türkei und zwar die episode von einer
verheirateten frau
sie trifft heimlich aber ohne böse
absichten den verlobten ihrer jugend und
wird vom eifersüchtigen und
gewalttätigen ehemann zur rede gestellt
mas
die märkte bescherten
sollte es an lena anna
ende
ja ein politisch engagierte film ein
brisantes thema mars ii goldberg
eigentlich ein film wie man ihn sich
wünscht
ich denke schon was man in dieser szene
sieht es auch eine große stärke bei sm
sex ist er gut im stimmungen kreieren
diese beklemmende atmosphäre die
emotionen die gänge hoch ich nehme an
dass wir auch so sein für leute die nur
dieser ausschnitt sie hin und nicht den
ganzen film kennen diese gabe hat sich
schon in ihren kurzfilmen gezeigt sie
hat übrigens die zwischen hochschule der
künste abgeschlossen
in regie und dass das sieht man auch in
diesem film dass man einfach mit geht
dass es überhaupt kein unterhaltsamer
film im sinn von von glücklichen
gefühlen aber der fesselt einen wirklich
fertigung aus letztes ich denke diese
schauspielerin die welt gesehen haben
die bären tun es ist auch als beste
darstellerin nominiert und ich denke sie
zurecht und sie lebt und arbeitet
übrigens in der schweiz strom tags in
dieser partie nachnominiert werden
der ist tatsächlich intensiv und einen
großen anteil daran hat auch der
kameramann kapelle st
diese drei geschichten unheimlich gut im
heutigen istanbul verortet ohne dass es
geschmacklich wird allerdings gegen ende
finde ich merkt man jetzt kommt der
politische teil jetzt will sie
aufrütteln und das läuft dann in eine
tödliche nein alle drei geschichten
gehen blutig aus und das fand ich dann
etwas sehr drehbuch ich wo ich dann zb
finde heidi hat einen viel besseren
spannungsbogen hingekriegt aus dieser
comic basiert auf einem buch das schon
viel bewährt ist schon viele gute bilder
schlecht kopiert wurden das heißt noch
lange nicht dass das einen guten film
geben muss ist diese musik ist ja mit 19
in die schweiz gekommen
die regisseurin weil sie darauf neben
der türkei mal im gefängnis waren muss
kam dann in die schweiz hat die
schwimmschule gemacht man spürt da so
wirklich auch eben eine dringlichkeit
bei ihr diese geschichte zu erzählen die
vielleicht ich sage mal preis sekunde
aus vielleicht da ist das eben dinge
erlebt haben die wirklich dann dringen
zinssätzen ich glaube auch und ich
glaube dieser film ist absolut zu recht
im rennen erinnert mich manchmal ein
bisschen an mustern der für die
franzosen ins oscar rennen gegangen ist
da wird auch nur türkisch gesprochen ich
möchte aber noch etwas anknüpfen sagen
zu bären tun
die hat mir auch wunderbar gefallen aber
es gibt eine schau sprechen die war noch
viel besser die ist nicht nominieren und
das meinem artikel oder nein nein nein
nein eine spielen die hier im gleichen
verlag allen
das ist die transsexuelle und da möchte
ich doch anregend dass wenn eine figur
den film so trägt wie diese figur dann
sollte die auch für den schweizer
filmpreis nominiert werden können
in deutschland ist das ganz übliche was
man hat den deutschen filmpreis gewonnen
letztes jahr also das sollte wohl auch
in der schweiz möglich sein aber weil
sie eben eine türkin ist kann sie nicht
nominiert werden richtig da vielleicht
um diesen film auch noch kurz
abzuschließen das ist ein schweizer film
obwohl türkisch gesprochen türkisch in
der türkei spielt weiter finanztrick
nicht gewöhnlich sind schon zu viel und
auch die regisseurin ist aus der schweiz
aber wenn der film in der welt gezeigt
wird werden alle sagen wie bei mustang
auch das ist ein türkischer film
das entspricht der heutigen realität wir
leben in einer multikulturellen
gesellschaft deshalb so zurecht
nominiert bleiben wir bei den
nominierten filmen im rennen ist auch
ein heimatfilm ein etwas anderer
heimatfilm nämlich heimatland 10
regisseure haben diesen film realisiert
zwei frauen zu acht männer alle zwischen
30 und 40
die premiere hatte dieser film in
locarno letzten werke in deutschland an
einem festival die zeitung da hat
geschrieben wichtigste schweizer film
des jahres
erzählt wird eine apokalyptische
geschichte die schweiz wird bedroht von
einer wolke von einem sturm alle möchten
flüchten aber nur die die eben nicht
schweizer sind dürfen die schweiz
verlassen
ich bin die unsere aufmerksamkeit
die europäische union hat beschlossen
mit sofortiger wirkung keine weiteren
schweizer flüchtige mehr zu nehmen
die europäische union ist auch nicht
weiter staatsbürger sind auf weiteres
untersagt in der glocken so unglücklich
die keinen fall
in st
so kam enke zum land
pumpen bitte gehen sie zurück
und die dürfen
der topfen oder was
auch ein politischer film
eine umkehrung der aktuellen
flüchtlingslager provokativ kann man
sagen
spätestens da warten junge regisseure
was ich finde schon näher und ich war
sehr begeistert dass ich diese bilder
gesehen habe
die bleiben haften das sind sehr
symbolische bilder man hat das boot ist
voll man hat auch diese staumauer die
quasi die isolationspolitik die
abschottungspolitik der schweizer
poliert
das zieht sich durch den ganzen film und
obwohl sein kollektiv film ist von zehn
jungen schweizer filme machen hat man
nie das gefühl das ist ein patchwork
sondern das ist aus einem guss das hat
einen look und das kommt als homogenes
ganzes daher im einzelnen finde ich hat
viele dramaturgische schwächen aber so
als ganzes finde ich dass ein wurf als
ganz großes teures kino das eben nicht
so teuer war ja ich habe große
sympathien für das dieses projekt und
vor allem finde ich cool das mal junge
unmittelbar auf eine aktualität eine
politische reagiert haben und in
nützlicher frist nach dem jahr zur
masseneinwanderung initiative als
antwort diesen film gemacht haben nur
diese ganzen symbole die sie mir dann
auch ein bisschen zu einfach ich war
eigentlich intellektuell unterfordert in
diesem film wieder alles so erklärt es
ist ja klar dass diese wolke
symbolischen wert hat
die kommt aus der innerschweiz das ist
die strafe für die politik der
nationalkonservativen und für den fall
dass es irgendeinen hinterbänklerin kino
noch nicht begriffen hätte konnten auch
schon ziegler und erklärt die
großwetterlage aufnahme wurde er ich
habe das als er kam war es für mich zu
viel weil immer wenn geredet wird oder
wenn zu viel geredet wird in diesem film
der die schwächsten stellen weil da bin
ich mit ihnen absolut einer meinung dass
wir wirklich nicht nötig gewesen und das
nimmt dem film ein bisschen diese
allegorische kraft die bilder besitzen
was ich mir hat er nicht so gewirkt
alles aus einem guss ich als sehr stark
gemerkt dass viele verschiedene leute da
am werk sind das vielleicht so viele
küche
ich denke für den
für den schnitt war das eine große
leistung und mit recht ist davon auch
der kategorie schnitt nominiert wie man
aus diesen diversen geschichten eine
einzige geschichte zusammenstellen kann
aber dramaturgisch ging für mich vieles
nicht auf es würden figuren eingeführten
sie verschwinden sollen oder es gibt
diverse figuren die vielleicht so
ähnlich sind
es gibt mehrere verrückte frauen in dem
film dies soll dann eine sehr ähnliche
funktion haben
ich denke auf der ebene der kritiker
florian keller hat gesagt ja schon sei
der perfekte sturm war für mich der
perfekte songs perfekt
ich denke das ist ja auch aber
schließlich finde ich den film vor allem
wichtig wegen dieser aussage die schweiz
die sich abschottet vermeintlich wegen
der sicherheit
und genau diese aufstockung wird ihr zum
verhängnis das hat meine diese
ausschnitte gesehen und diese düsteren
stimmungen diese endzeitstimmung davon
lebte 5 vor allem und auf der ebene
funktionierte sehr gut also noch etwas
unbeholfen eigentlich mit guter absicht
aber noch etwas unbeholfen höre ich da
ran
trotzdem denke ich dass das wenn man in
20 jahren die geschichte des schweizer
teams in den zehn jahren schreiben wir
das ganze ein wichtiger film sein wird
weil das so eine art statement ist es
ist eine abkehr vom reinen
unterhaltungskino da kommt eine neue
generation ich habe dieses bild von
locarno wo diese leute in der fast
ausverkauften halle auf der bühne
standen und einen optimismus verströmt
das war wie ein statement hier sehen wir
sind viele wir sind jung und wir machen
jetzt wieder freches kino und das hat
mich schon sehr berechenbar vielleicht
auch mal über diese macht oder
respektive dieses kollektiv also zehn
leute die zusammen sich zusammenraufen
oder kann man sagen und einen film
machen miteinander
das braucht doch irgendwie eine
generation die das auch kann ja das sind
ja alles unter 40 jährige zwischen 30
und 40 mittlerweile unter der leitung
von michael krummenacher der ist hier
ganz links
und da hat es auch namen dringt die man
schon kennt also ein jan gassmann
den kannte man schon der hat er gut
gemacht und ein tobias möller hat jetzt
auf der berlinale alois gezeigt da kommt
eine generation und die trägt zusammen
auf und widerlegt das klischee dass
unsere jugend oder unsere jungen
erwachsenen muss man ja eigentlich sagen
dass die apolitisch sind und das
widerlegt auch ein klischee vom
autorenkino
in der schweiz wird manchmal das
autorenkino falsch verstanden dass
cheney brütet im stillen kämmerlein bis
das werk so weit ist lars von trier ken
loach oder auch unsere ursula meier die
arbeitnehmer zu zweiten sind dadurch
viel schneller natürlich zum schluss mit
ursula meier firma der in ken loachs
film aber die haben ihre partner und
wenn eben eben zu zehnt ist kann man
auch schneller arbeiten und
unmittelbaren auf die aktualität wobei
die sich ja die köpfe eingeschlagen
haben auch im wahrsten sinne des wortes
ich hab gelesen dass die wirklich da auf
dem schnitt am schnittplatz gestritten
hausen sich dies auch unendlich
kompliziert gemacht auch dadurch mit
dieser form des sogenannten cinema und
weil alle mit alle zehn episoden
geliefert haben und vielleicht nicht so
ganz miteinander abgesprochen haben wie
diese erzählstränge miteinander
zusammenhängen
ich denke daher kommt die die schwäche
des films aber dass ich finde es auch
spanien vorher wurde gesagt dass diese
firma einer art heimatfilm ist und das
möchte ich auch unterstützen
er ist ein kritischer heimatfilm aber
ganz klar auch ein heimatfilm ein film
der sich mit der schweizer sondern sich
selbst beschäftigt und dass so etwas
auch aus gruppenarbeit gemacht wird
finde ich auch sehr berechtigt weil eben
der autorenfilm vom einzelnen genie im
keller der hätte vielleicht nicht diese
reichweite aus einem film der wirklich
aus einer demokratischen quasi dem
demokratischen prozess auch entstanden
wobei im schlusspaar weniger
demokratisch ich denke dass so wie sie
den film gemacht haben das ist auch ein
parallel zu der art und weise wie man
möchte dass die schweizer funktionieren
würde
ironisch dass sie eigentlich den spieß
umkehren weil das angst machen die
bedrohung der schweizer auf beschwerden
ist das camp
öfter nationalkonservativen spricht der
svp und hier kehren sie den spieß um und
sagen ja ihr seid der ursprung der
probleme und dann diese abriegelung der
schweiz die wir dann aus der anderen
perspektive erleben und die überdies
haben sie haben gleich noch gedreht wie
markus imhof das boot ist das fand ich
schon irgendwo und last not least für
mich ist das auch ein bisschen eine
rückkehr von bern
weil die initiative kam hier aus bern
und bern war so lange zeit wie
verschwunden die motoren im schweizer
film waren zürich und lausanne genf und
diese bern arbeiten häufig im kollektiv
und ich freue mich wenn da noch mehr
kommt aus diesem biotop was zeichnet
denn diese generation nennen wir sie
heimatland wie sie glaube auch von der
swiss films promotion agentur genannt
wird generation heimatland ich glaube
sie sind alle sehr heimatverbunden aber
sie haben auch die meisten von ihnen
haben den sprung ins ausland gewagt
kachel auch studiert krummenacher hat
mit gassmann in münchen studiert neue
hat in new york studiert und ich glaube
gott für diesen film ist sehr
bezeichnend und wichtig dass man diesen
blick von außen mal auf die schweiz
wirft und wie wirkt das ganze michael
krummenacher hat mir auch im interview
erzählt also von münchen zurück in die
schweiz kam und am hauptbahnhof
plötzlich diese plakate gesehen habe hat
er gedacht wo bin ich hier und diese
blick von außen gleicht diese
ausländische einfluss nicht nur positiv
auf die bildsprache auswirkt weil für
mich ist es auch eine relativ wie soll
ich sagen
also eine neutrale bildsprache oder eine
bildsprache die sich auch durch das
internationale vielen seen beeinflussen
ließ auf effekte aus und das sieht man
auch glaube ich ich werde etwas
ähnliches später sorgen zu einem anderen
film in dieser runde dass man vielleicht
bestimmte erwartungen hat was ist eine
professionelle kameraführung war man
sich im internationalen vergleich
behaupten möchte und dadurch gehen
vielleicht bestimmte besonderheiten oder
eine bestimmte stimmung ein bisschen
verloren
ich denke der ist fast postmodern weil
er sich
überall ein bisschen bedient also der
rat elemente vom französischen autoren
kino ich denke da die polizisten die mit
dem nigerianischen flüchtlingen zusammen
beträgt der in ihren erinnerungen wieder
kommt sie hat ihn vermutlich erschossen
und andererseits bedienen sie sich
schamlos beim katastrophen kino aus
hollywood die art des evoque inszeniert
ist erinnerte ein wenig an independence
day und das sagt mir irgendwie gefallen
dieses unverkrampfte mission also die
ältere garde der filmemacher in der
schweiz müssen sich warm anziehen
wegen dieser jungen truppe ich hoffe es
ich hoffe also die anzeichen stehen ja
gut also sie sind überall auf den
festivals vertreten haben gassmann war
auch wieder in berlin
der erfolg gibt ihm recht warum könnten
sie vielleicht nicht wieder
zusammenarbeiten wie damals frelimo und
vitus das vielleicht in einem jahr das
man die generationen gegeneinander
ausspielte lang gemacht und vielleicht
das nächste mal 1 1 1 1
episoden film machen mit leuten als
diversen generation weil ich habe mich
glaube dass sie den bruch mit der alten
generation suchen
dass die älteren meinen die eltern die
aus 68 und früher gegen ihre eltern
abgegrenzt haben jetzt wenn sie die
jungen doof und wenn man dann sagt sie
müssten sich noch warm anziehen dann
konnte ich lerne dass die inhaltliche
wieder bei den 68ern knüpfen sie kümmern
sich um die eigenen angelegenheiten sind
aber abzeichnen ein kritisches schweiz
bild und damit umgehen sie eigentlich
diese generation dazwischen michael
steigerung konzerten die sich ihrem
alten schweizer film von schmied
orientiert haben oder bei ginobili mit
herbstzeitlosen da jetzt wieder
politischer bleiben wir bei neuen jungen
talenten oder neuen talenten auch neuen
gesichtern die zukunft wird ja auch
sichtbar mir ist aufgefallen
dieses jahr dass es viele neue
schauspielerinnen schauspieler gibt die
man sehen kann auf den verschiedenen in
verschiedenen filmen leinwänden und ein
film ist natürlich bestückt mit vielen
jungen schauspielerinnen
schauspiel das ist eins von niklaus
hilber ein film über sex über sechs
fantasien vor allem aber über
gruppendruck bei teenager im zeitalter
von social media
so komisch du kannst auch geordnet zum
nachnamen sie sind kein fan von diesem
film
ich bin leider kein fan von diesem film
ich gönne ihm den ganzen erfolg denn er
hatte preisaktion festival wünschen
alles gute aber gerade diese szene zeigt
einiges was mich aufregt dass fünf junge
mädchen jede mit mund und die machen
diese nummer mit der zigarette das ist
irgendwie einfach für mich eine reine
fantasie wie die drehbuchautoren die
zwei männer sind in meinem alter sich
vorstellen wie teenager miteinander
umgehen und vor allem weibliche als ich
muss dazu sagen dass sie wütend geworden
beim schauen ja nicht wütend aber
irgendwie das ist einfach ich mich
überzeugt das nicht
und auf den pausen uns ich nein ich
denke wenn man wenn man genau in dieser
szene sieht man auch wieder führung für
mich auch ein bisschen hadert zwischen
möchte er wirklich realistisch sein und
dokumentarisch ein schweizer pausenplatz
deutschschweizer passen dokumentieren
nochmals inszenieren oder möchte er mehr
im genre kino teenie film wie man das
aus dem amerikanischen kino kennt wo
möchte er unterwegs sein und hier ist es
genau so ein hin und her
wir lassen christian jung so weit kommt
für ihn ist es der beste schweizer film
zeit lang genau was er macht etwas etwas
extrem schwierig ist arbeitet mit jungen
darstellern das wissen schon die leute
die heute und schellen ursli gemacht
haben wie wichtig wie schwierig das ist
überhaupt mit einem jungen zu arbeiten
dann hat man aber noch bruno ganz
daneben hier ist es ein ganzes kollektiv
und die sind durchs band weg sehr gut
gekostet
und für meine ohren sprechen die
unglaublich authentisch wundert auch
manchmal bekommt man das ja mit dem tram
wenn zwei so girls am handy sind um
miteinander reden und ich finde das auch
gut dass er sehr nah an diesen
jugendlichen erzählt und das ganze so
ein bisschen wie eine reportage
strukturiert hat es gibt dann
zwischendurch immer wieder soweit
blenden
damit man als zuschauer im moment zeit
hat zu verarbeiten was man gerade
gesehen hat und ich finde es unglaublich
authentisch diesen film einmal mit einer
super-serie peters ich bin eher auf
dieser seite ich fand ihn auch sehr
authentisch ich finde dieses bild von
diesen mädchen ist nicht schmeichelhaft
aber es ist ungefähr so das was ich
mitkriege wenn ich zugfahrer wenn ich
zuhörer wie die mädchen sich miteinander
austauschen auch die jungs natürlich
genau im gleichen ausmaß aber die
sprache gerade die sprache hat mir hier
sehr gut gefallen
es gibt eine szene unter jungs da reden
die über pornos und dann sagt der eine
zum anderen kaiser auf xp zugängen
bergen also für so einen satz muss man
den film lieben weil das ist wirklich so
sprechen die jungen leute und das habe
ich auch schon gehört oder manchmal
sogar hatte ich hier das gefühl ich höre
noch mehr als ich im zuhören würde weil
das zensuriert sie wollen dass er nicht
offen aussprechen aber mich mir
erscheint es sehr echt mal gold dagegen
für sie in ihr nun klingt das fleisch
also ich denke der film setzt sich auf
jeden fall mit problemen auseinander die
sehr echt und relevante und aktuell sind
und genau diese frage was für einen
einfluss haben die sozialen medien auf
das teenager leben heutzutage aber ich
habe mir ein problem mit der art und
weise wieder für ein konstruiertes
wieder her kommt ich denke die
schauspielerische leistung von diesen
jungen menschen ist enorm
und ich versuche das jetzt zu erklären
eben genau diese sache wenn man sich
gewohnt ist viele teenies filme zu sehen
dann gibt es schon bestimmte muster oder
bestimmte klischees die immer wieder
vollkommen wir haben das hier gerade
gesehen die intriganten oder die die
wenn ich das so sagen darf die [ __ ]
die die am sexisten ist die dann die
gruppe queen bee wie man auf englisch
sagt war meine firmen wenigen große auch
immer wieder gesehen
der film zum teil lehnt sich an solchen
modellen und gleichzeitige hatte die
ansprüche irgendwie echt und realistisch
und dokumentarisch und es werden
erzählstränge angefangen wo man das
gefühl hat dass solche in bestimmte
richtungen gehen dabei ist das gar nicht
der fall also ich glaube ihm nicht wie
er wir daher kommt und vor allem wie die
geschichte ausgehen und das die
geschichte vom opfer match in der
situation möchte ich aber sagen aber ich
glaube das kommt noch
wir schauen dass noch im unterschied zum
beispiel zurück wo sie auch in eine
tragödie hineinläuft läuft finde ich
diesen viel glaubwürdiger wurde habe ich
auch inspiriert von einem fall in
seebach war das glaub ich worden was ein
mädchen wurde dann aber von jahr von
einer gruppen gangbang eigentlich also
die herstellung und ich finde er hat
einen dokumentarischen geste aber es ist
eigentlich schon klar dass das ein
einspielfilm ist dass ich sehe da es
dieses problem nicht wirklich und für
mich ist er eine ganze zeit echt das ist
alles so echt und das ist super echt und
gleichzeitig ist er gar nicht so recht
von der dramaturgie her von den
hauptfiguren her
das ist ganz klar irgendwie team einfach
nicht und hat im prinzip eigentlich drei
akten
also wurde die form wir reden über die
form auch auf ebendiese weiß bänke sind
ja immer sehr genaue blick in eine szene
hinein oder also habe ich wahrgenommen
also man schaut in eine szene rhein nahe
bei den jugendlichen die erwachsenen
sind ja fast inexistent und geht wieder
raus ist super peinlich und super was
auch das auch wahrscheinlich stimmt für
mich hat die deutschland der erwachsenen
mehr bestimmen auf eine art in ihrer
ganzen peinlichkeit und ahnungslosigkeit
aber dann schauen wir uns doch mal eine
schauspielerin eine junge ein bisschen
genauer an ist eines dieser neuen
talente annina wollt sie ist für den
schweizer filmpreis als beste
schauspielerin nominiert vielleicht muss
man sagen sie ist auch bei nicht
passiert als beste schauspieler
nominiert also zwei nominationen für
annina wald und an ihnen bald wurde vor
ungefähr drei jahren von corina klaus
der kanzlerin entdeckt und sie sagt oder
hat mal gesagt eben dass die annina
wollte hat ein blick der kann
geschichten erzählen
nach tageszeit
wo
moxas 8
über folter zu versteckt haben das war
eine clique
der bald 19-jährige zweifach nominiert
für den schweizer filmpreis als beste
schauspielerin kristin jungen zurecht
absolut verdient ich hoffe allerdings
dass ihnen für amateur teams gewinnt
weil sie hier deutlich besser ist genau
als im film von micha lewinsky und ich
finde was da corinna klaus gesagt hat
absolut zutreffend sie ist eine
schauspielerin die eben mit dem gesicht
etwas erzählen kann und die fast besser
ist wenn sie nur drei entscheidung nicht
nicht so viel spricht und das denke ich
ist eine ein großes versprechen für den
schweizer film und ich hoffe dass diese
karriere jetzt weitergeht weil dies ja
erst 19 jahre alt und da ist immer die
frage schwingt jetzt auf die schulische
oder akademische laufbahn ein oder hat
sie wieder rollenangebote und ich hoffe
sie dass sie weiter arbeiten kann auch
einverstanden
ein zukunfts talent doch auf jeden fall
so dass ganz groß ist eine sehr begabte
schauspieler wenn sie weiß mit weniger
mehr zu machen
was mich allerdings gestellt hat in
diesem film wie auch im film nichts
passiert ist eben die rolle die sie
spielt als opfer weil sie da nicht
wirklich die hauptfigur ist sondern als
opfer
sie muss geopfert werden damit es
anderen er in der geschichte besser geht
beziehungsweise damit die geschichte der
anderen losgeht oder weitergezogen will
dass sie ihre ganzes leiden nimmt aus
wendepunkt in der dramaturgie der
geschichte
das ist nichts passiert noch mehr der
fall serien hauptrolle lasse sie wird in
beiden fällen vergewaltigt damit an
damit damit anderen menschen mit anderen
menschen etwas erleben und ich meine
nicht die die sie vergewaltigt haben
sondern das hat eine auswirkung auf die
anderen figuren im film und das ist für
mich wirklich so eine
instrumentalisierung von dieser
opferrolle
also ich verstehe dieses argument mit
der instrumentalisierung aber ich finde
bei amateur teams trifft sie nicht zu
weil ich habe sie jetzt als hauptfigur
gelesen dass dieses films für mich war
es in zentral und deswegen finde ich
auch richtig ist sie nominiert worden
als beste darstellerin und nicht in
einer nebenrolle zu
die titelfigur ist es ist nämlich dass
er ich ja also ich finde sie in dieser
rolle auch stärker als in nichts
passiert doppel nominationen leicht aus
ihr übertragen das finde ich das macht
die schweiz kleiner als sie ist jetzt
das sollte man verhindern weil man
könnte auch sagen annina wald ist
nominiert für diese zwei filme dann gibt
es noch zwei weitere darsteller weil man
stelle sich vor bei den oscars meryl
streep die anschuldigung aber schon
geben das gibt es immer wieder ja aber
es ließe sich so einfach verhindern
deswegen sollte man es tun
es ist auch nicht so dass die auswahl
sehr groß ist weil ihnen schweizer
deutschschweizer spielfilmen häufig
ausländerinnen die hauptrollen spielen
dafür dass man eben auch mit einbezieht
wie zb isabelle bei home die sich sogar
darüber aufgeregt dass sie nicht
nominiert
wenn es natürlich dann mit dieser bei
liebherr kommst dann kannst du lange
warten bis wieder ein gewinn
aber vielleicht alternativen sag ich mal
gehabt um nicht eine doppel nomination
zu lancieren
vielleicht ist auch eine doppel
nomination im schweizer filmpreis dieses
jahr vielleicht ganz kurz chancen für
annina wald sie hat ja eigentlich zwei
drittel chancen zu gewinnen
es ist ja eigentlich eine gewinnerin
weil das geld gibt es für die nomination
das hat jetzt doppelt gekriegt und wenn
sie nicht gewinnt wird jeder sagen aber
sie war doch doppelt nominiert
ich glaube sie gewinnt für amateur teams
auch wobei ich würde mich auch für die
berliner freuen
das werde auch andere leerzeichen selbst
sagt aber ich denke in diesem fall wenn
beides berechtigt übrigens das
hinzufügen die meisten filme nominierten
filme sind auch kompliziert vom
schweizer fernsehen und unsere sendungen
die berichten auf verschiedenen kanälen
im radio im fernsehen online immer
wieder auch über die nominierten filme
und die schauspielerinnen
schauspieler nominiert sind das kann man
sich ansehen auf unserer spezialseite
diese beiträge und da geht übrigens auch
ein film quiz bei dem sie mitmachen
können und es winken attraktive preise
zum beispiel zwei plätze für den
eröffnungsfilm auf der piazza grande am
filmfestival von locarno inklusive einer
hotelübernachtung und wir schauen jetzt
in den dokumentarfilm hinein bester
dokumentarfilm da ist uns und nicht nur
uns vor allem ein film ins auge
gestochen ein virtueller paukenschlag
und bildung
diese firma viel aufmerksamkeit bekommen
reihe tigers film branchenblatt zählt
ihn zu den zehn wichtigsten filmen des
jahres eher brav and below
der regisseur dieses films der ist einer
der mal die mädchenherzen zum schmelzen
oder höher schlagen ließ und zwar als
langhaariger soldat in der erfolgreichen
schweizer komödie achtung fertig
zöllners
der walliser nicolas steiner
er hat eben dann sich hinter die kamera
zurück gezogen hat in deutschland
studiert und hat jetzt einen
abschlussfilm hervorgebracht er es eben
ab und below und da steigt er hinunter
in die abwasserkanäle unter las vegas
und porträtiert da randfiguren
randständige in den usa sozusagen die
kehrseite des amerikanischen traums
rem
christian jung nach bei diesem film
haben sie geschrieben ein meisterwerk
und ich habe nochmals geschafft und bin
immer noch überzeugt das ist ein
meisterwerk ist er machte etwas was die
68 oder des neuen schweizer spiels schon
gemacht haben er porträtiert außenseiter
leute die nicht auf dem rather sind die
unten sind zb eben in diesen flut
kanälen von las vegas leben aber im
unterschied zu den 68ern
ist es nicht ein anwaltschaftliche firma
oder der regisseur verbrüdert sich nicht
gerade mit diesen leuten sondern er
zeigt einfach mal wie die leben zeigt
ihre lebenswelt und inszenierte ihn
wirklich bildung von zu klima schönheit
da gibt es ein typ der lebt in der wüste
von kalifornien und geht jeden morgen
den sonnenaufgang schauen und man hat
irgendwie was zuschauer das gefühl man
möchte auch schon dort leben und das ist
die art wie wir ihnen sympathie
entgegenbringt indem er sie ihre
lebenswelt extrem schön und würde wohl
darstellt und mit der zeit waren diese
leute auch anfängt zu erzählen woher sie
kommen
was sich hinter sich haben und da kommen
biographien hervor mit großen brüchen
und das entwickelt so einen sog der er
wirklich faszinierend ist
ich habe den fernseher gern geschaut ich
bin allerdings nicht so ganz
vorbehaltlos überzeugt davon wie
christian jungen ich denke im vergleich
zu den 68ern oder zur nutzung zur
dokumentarfilm tradition dieser film hat
ganz klar eine sehr schnellen ästhetik
eine sehr gepflegte ästhetik grenz
manchmal schon an inszenierung ist alles
kein problem
das hat man früher auch bemängelte
bedauert dass die dokfilm manchmal zu
wenig schön gewesen sind
zu wenig eine schöne bild sprache
gepflegt haben
aber in diesem fall habe ich das gefühl
dass die ästhetik dem thema ein bisschen
im weg steht war dieser film ist auch
ein politischer film es geht nicht nur
um einzelne outsiders sondern es geht um
ganz viele themen in den usa
dass es diese armut gibt dass die leute
aus dem militär zurückkommen
traumatisiert und nicht gepflegt werden
das ist ein haus in crysis 2 wurde dass
leute ihr zuhause verloren haben dass
man mit dem um mit der umwelt nicht
richtig umgeht und und und das sind
alles themen die hier angesprochen
werden
aber der firma geht fast eine des fast
zwei stunden lang das dauert fast eine
stunde bis man in die persönlichen
geschichten der protagonisten einsteigt
und dann werden sie doch immer wieder
unterbrochen durch sehr schön
geschnittene montage sequenzen mit musik
wo man sich vielmehr auch irgendwie im
video
im musikvideo wähnt und ich finde es ein
bisschen schade das ist zwar schön und
auch sehr souverän sehr professionell
gemacht aber ich habe das ein bisschen
des themas
ich habe ihn dreimal gesehen ich würde
wahrscheinlich noch einmal sehe ich für
mich ist das der beste film den wir
heute besprechen
und es stimmt dieser film will nicht
missstände aufdecken sondern er hat eine
haltung eine philanthropische haltung
sogar aber es sehr nah an am wohl sein
der menschen interessiert also er hat
einen nicht werten im blick er
beobachtet und das mitgefühl ist überall
spürbar
aber es geht nicht um die einzelnen
messstellen es geht nicht darum dass die
drogenabhängig sind das die unter der
erde sondern er nimmt einfach diese ganz
unterschiedlichen geschichten macht
etwas völlig neues daraus und mit einer
arri alexa hat er das gedreht also die
werbe ästhetik die stimmt das ist
nämlich die kamera mit dem man werbespot
dreht und in mitte auch immer nur bett
ski jetzt drei mal den oscar gewonnen
hat
es ist ein spielfilm kamera also schon
nur die wahl der kamera zeigt da wollte
jemand große ästhetik machen und für
mich ist es auch ab
mit gelungen weil der film ist sowas von
poesie wir sehen hier das bild mit dem
trauma das ist ja absolut auch
inszeniert also die hat ja nicht
automatisch dann solche feuerwerke
dahingehend dass gutes unsere filme
jetzt auch wieder etwas besser aussehen
weil diese miefige ästhetik des 60 70er
jahre kinos die ist sowas von passe und
auch nicht mehr zeitgemäß und es ist
halt ein charakteristikum übrigens auch
bei heimatland hat extrem attraktive
bilder die nah am ästhetisieren sind
auch bei köpfe und das scheint ein
bisschen ein merkmal dieser generation
zu sein aber ich finde das gut das macht
die macht die filme auch bekömmlicher
und ich meine auch unsere national
reiter nationalrätinnen sehen heute
hübsche und besser als damals in den
sechziger und siebziger jahren das
entspricht 1 ganz einfach dem dem zeit
als früher muss allerdings ein problem
den christian frei unsere großen
dokumentarfilmer war fotograf hat man ja
immer vorgehalten der mache geleckte
bilder und schafft es nie verstanden ist
doch toll wenn die bilder schön sind im
fall der politiker finde ich es nicht
nur begrüßenswert dass so viel mehr wert
gelegt wird auf das äußere erscheinung
und es nur mit föhnfrisur und so weiter
ich bin es auch so ehrlich früher ist
man auch in sendungen wie diese gesessen
mit irgendeiner komischen frisur und hat
sogar geraucht und musste nicht so
darauf achten dass ich denke dass das
die gesellschaft sich in die richtung
hin bewegt hat für äußerlichkeit es
nicht nur begrüßenswert aber jetzt im
zusammenhang mit diesem film wie gesagt
ich finde es sehr interessant ich finde
sie einfach nicht unbedingt immer im
dienst des themas und für mich ist der
film nicht nur im zeichen von mitgefühl
ich denke der regisseur hat ganz bewusst
leute ausgewählt das ist das thema ist
genau daraufhin below leute die vor
allem kein zuhause haben die wirklich am
rande leben die zum teil an den rand
getrieben wurden
die in einem sehr geladen losen
gesellschaft leben und ich glaube dass
es nicht nur zufall dass das so groß
thematisiert wird im film ich nehme an
das war auch noch eine absicht des
autors und von denen aus sie sind
kontraproduktiv dass man dann auch wenn
wir sind zwischendurch diese sequenzen
hat mit musik und getrommelt und eben
bisschen ein bisschen video mäßig man
hat nicht den raum den man brauchen
würde zum wirklich darüber nachdenken
was diese menschen gerade gesagt haben
war das sind zum teil
das sind erstaunliche darsteller auch
das politische und diesem film ist doch
gerade dass er so einen typen nicht wie
ein armen tropf inszeniert sondern zeigt
das ist auch ein mitbürger der kann
sogar ein star sein da wird er die hier
mit feuerwerk inszeniert das eben das
politische das nicht sofort auf diese
misere die in einem schönen kontext und
ihnen damit eine gute gibt dass man das
so schön zeigt und gleichzeitig das
event findet in der kanalisation etwas
erhabenes und er meint das ernst und
wenn man empfänglich dafür ist dann
spürt man das also ich spiele sehr viel
liebe und sehr viel poesie in diesem
film und das ist auch ein unterschied
leben zu diesen harten zeiten porträt
der 68 die 68er waren immer zornige
leute da sieht man ja bei markus imhof
das boot ist voll war zornig und modern
harley war immer noch zornig mehr als 30
jahre danach der kommt mir eher vor der
nicholas steiner life is good luck
celebrated der macht total positiven
film und mir gefällt dass ich mitgehe
nicht nur ins kino und durch die montur
über mich einbrechen zu lassen
also ich glaube über diesen film kann
man diskutieren wir sehen ist und der
läuft ja auch noch im kino also man kann
sich den anschauen und sich an die
närrischen treibens mit dem zins wird
kommen wir zum schluss zu einer kurzen
schlussrunde
wir haben über eine handvoll filme
diskutiert sie natürlich ja nicht alle
über die wir geredet haben aber sind das
jetzt für sie auch die favoriten für den
schweizer filmpreis
die eben den preis gewinnen werden also
wir haben über köpfe heimatland
amateurteams
in der kategorie dokumentarfilm sind das
die favoriten also ab auf 1 bill ist als
bester dokumentarfilm nominiert und für
den besten schnitt von kaya in der
abendländischen auch heimatland
geschnittenen auch eine doppel
nomination absolut verdient aber ich
finde dieser film mit dieser musik
müsste auch in der kategorie musik
nominiert sein kann er nicht weil
ausländische produktion und auch lebens
der kamera mit markus nestroy dem
kameramann großer favorit wie sie
spielfilm mein kopf sagt gepäck um das
herz das herz wird wahrscheinlich sogar
zu einem film tendierenden wir heute gar
nicht besprochen haben nämlich nichts
passiert nichts passiert von micha
lewinsky eine schwarze komödie
ich würde gerne eine lanze brechen für
zwei filme jetzt nicht erwähnt wurden in
dieser runde
ich finde lena bauer ist wirklich einer
der begabtesten regisseur in der schweiz
im moment der hat auch neben ostermayer
und einigen anderen ausnahmen fast am
meisten anerkennung als dem ausland und
ich finde in der schweiz geht ein
bisschen unter man müsste ihn ein
bisschen ernster nehmen in seinem tun
also dass ihr favorit einer säule so
also lockt viele vielleicht dass er ich
wäre nicht unglücklich wenn köpfe
gewinnen würde aber ich möchte auch nach
und bei den dokfilm schlägt mein herz
ehrlich gesagt für den 5 von einer
dominique über hiroshima aus die sonne
vom himmel fiel
der hat mich sehr überzeugt weil das
einerseits ein film ist über ein großes
thema katastrophe von hiroshima und
fukushima die ganze ganze thema
atomkraft gleichzeitig ist es eine
persönliche familiengeschichte die
geschichte ihres großvaters daraus arzt
in hiroshima tätig war und ich finde die
bilder sind in diesem film auch sehr
schön und auch sehr stimmig also im
dienst ist als die sonne ins innendienst
von meyer dominik auch kann man im
moment im kino anschauen
auch wenn man sich eine meinung nach
eine ganz kurze strecke gewinnen wir
körperlich mein favorit ist amateur
teams und wenn bei den dokumentarfilmen
nicht mehr davon los gewinnt dann ist
etwas schiefgelaufen
also herzlichen dank für diese
einschätzungen maximo park ist den
jungen seele peterson danke dass sie da
waren am freitagabend wissen wir mehr
nämlich um 18 29 uhr live auf sf 2 wird
die verleihung
betragen im fernsehen und anschließend
dann sprechen wir mit den gewinnern
ungefähr um 20 14 ja und da sehen wir
uns dann wieder ist dann ich wünsche
eine schöne woche schauen sie filme vor
allem schweizer film
o